there's some fucking go into that deep
country music what were you just telling
me about country music that some giant
country rap yeah what is the song it's
called Old Town Road Old Town Road yes
one of the biggest songs out it's at the
my it's number one on the regular charts
in the country charts right put it
together little nas X is that right
everyone's little X little NAS what a
little nas X but so he was on the
country charged they took him off cuz
like this isn't country man but then he
linked up with Miley Cyrus's dad what's
his name
Billy Ray sorry really Ray Cyrus how
dare you yes I think what also had to do
with this is he used out whether he did
it or not I don't know but he used the
video game Red Dead Redemption and some
of the cool graphics and then made rap
song country rap song it's called
country trap is what they're calling it
that's why oh it's a different thing but
it's got its got its catchy and it's
based around this kind of stuff it got
it got hot it caught they caught the
wave country like the DJs on all the
stations were like just ripping it off
with YouTube and playing it that's why I
made it on the Billboard and then sorted
like that's not-- this isn't a country
song take it off and then because that
almost sex tries to in effect it got
bigger so they um they who who took it
off billboard did why they take it off
because it doesn't and their third of
description was that it doesn't meet the
qualifications for country meet country
order Billy Ray Cyrus jumped on board
and then there's video of him and Billy
Ray Cyrus and you know it's so
interesting when you're looking at the
the footage of it how cool that fuckin
game there's just a game this is that's
a huge game right red redemption too but
what a great idea to rap over so smart
demson that's a genius idea because like
that game you played it in here good
game
yeah you guys beat the shit I mean
whatever game we played last night that
was quick
that's fuckin you don't want to fuck
with that game dude we're just Tom Papa
walked in Jeff and I were battling to
the death Tom Papa don't play you know
he was just watching us what the fuck
are you doing yeah what are you doing he
doing tom pop is so funny man he just
wants everything to be old-school he
said want to go to the to the paper
vendor and get a newspaper and bake his
own bread I take that what is this
Manson
but not with Billy Ray like a real video
now Wow yeah I'm not feeling the real
video do I like waiting to do dances
with a cowboy hat on though he's become
a star because of this it's getting
played all the festivals all the last
couple weeks
the crowds are loving it why didn't he
open up at Coachella it was already
booked it's more along it's it this
happened so quick you could sneak him in
there a Cyrus let bit you know you get
his whistle wet it coach a might have
played it I'm sure but like I saw that
little the yodel kid was singing this
song like he's even too long no do you
know who Billy Ray Cyrus is no you know
his big hit oh yeah don't keep breaking
my heart
anywhere this daughter's way bigger um
he was really huge for a brief moment in
time yeah yeah he was never like what
she is she's she's like a just sound to
his buck and she was on that crazy
Disney hit forever hand of my Hannah
Montana forever which made no sense
I put a wig on nobody notices because
it's so ridiculous like Batman there is
glorious locks god I think yeah he owes
brother yeah so powerful everybody was
doing the achy-breaky heart back down
93 million I bet that must have fucking
freaked him out man
thank us he was back then for that brief
moment in time dude don't you think it's
weird or now Mouse to be famous like
then you could get away with things and
now it's a nightmare yeah